cattle graze while the rainforest behind
them goes up in flames
if there is a shot that explains the
conflict between conservation
and exploitation of resources then this
is probably it
the rainforest the rivers and the
communities of the amazon
are shrouded in smoke the fires have
returned
and they're wreaking havoc here
christavo costa spent the last two days
fighting fires
engulfing his farm he lost
and this this was all on fire all all of
it
came
he took us through his cocoa plantation
it's been destroyed by fires from a next
door cattle ranch
three years of work to bring to market
his first crop of beans
gone in 24 hours
the brazilian government says there
aren't fires in the amazon
i put that to him is
[Music]
annie weren't on the farm when the fires
caught his neighbor told them to get
home
it was the worst journey of their lives
but christavo and his neighbor remondo
freyr believe that the land
can be farmed while preserving the
rainforest but they struggle to get
their voices heard in parts of the
rainforest
that have already been replaced by
farmland and now fires
the effects of the fires wild or
otherwise reach all society here
in paris state every day the town of
south felix dojingo
is immersed in smoke you don't just wear
masks for covid here
you need them to breathe the local mayor
won't openly criticize
the powerful ranchers or the brazilian
government but she is calling for help
uh
[Music]
the conflict between continuing
deforestation
and protecting the forest is acute here
but the more it goes on
the hotter the temperature gets
eventually you could reach a point
where there is no more forest but there
are no more farms
either stuart ramsey sky news
in the amazon rainforest